Mày mùng tăng tham ba, ngoài trình Trung Quốc vương nghị trở biến, bắt kinh khó mùng hộ quan điểm cho rằng
tất cả cường Quốc nên cùng quan trị thế giới.
Hãy biểu tệ của họ báo thủ nghiên bên lệ kỳ học đại hội đại biểu như dân tàn Quốc.
Ông nền mạnh, Trung Quốc sẽ không đi theo con đường chuyển thống,
mà một Cú Già mạnh tiền cách khi thích lập báo quyền.
Khi ông vương nghị, Trung Quốc và Mỹ là hai Cú Già của anh hưởng lớn trên Trung Quốc tế,
sẵn thế giới hiện có ông trong chimic Cú Già với lợi ấy và tình lời sien.
Nhà ngoại sống này trước rằng lịch sử thi giới đã tạo nên bởi sự tham gia của tất cả các khu xa,
còn tương lời của nhân loại, cần được kiến thảo chung bởi nhân dân thân tất cả.
Mọi trình Trung Quốc cũng nhấn mạnh, sự đáng sạn là đáng nghiệm từ nhân của sã hội loại người.
Trong khi, trở từ Cú tế đá cục được ơi, là hình thứ phu ngờ về bố cảnh hẹn này.
Phuôn điểm này phà nâng lập trường lống này của bắt kinh về việc thuộc đại một thẩy thống cú tế,
dội chiến hợp tác và tôn trọng lẫn nhau, ông vương nghị khẳng định rằng giù tình anh của tế thay đổi ra sao và Trung Quốc phát triển đến mức nào,
nếu này vẫn sẽ không tìm kiếm bà quen, hay mở ra hoàn hưởng thật các chuyện thống của các cửa cửa cửa cửa.